Okay.
So pretty big news.
In the last 24 hours, the governor of New
York, Andrew Cuomo, has signed a bill, which
would allow the release of Donald Trump's
state tax returns from the state of New York
specifically to one or up to three different
congressional committees.
Now, there are some people who think this
is the biggest deal in the world.
There are, Trump is too are saying this is
nothing.
And the truth is that it's potentially a moderately
big deal.
Remember, this is not Donald Trump's federal
taxes.
This is his New York state taxes.
Andrew Cuomo signed a bill yesterday, which
would allow three congressional committees
access to Trump state tax returns from New
York for a quote specified and legitimate
legislative purpose.
So now the three committees, if they want
to request Trump's New York state tax returns
on this basis, they're going to have to demonstrate
what is the specific legitimate legislative
purpose for obtaining Donald Trump's tax returns.
The three committees are the house ways and
means committee, the Senate Finance Committee,
and the joint committee on taxation, which
includes members of both the House and Senate.
So number one, there's still a very long way
to go here.
Can they actually demonstrate a specific and
legitimate legislative purpose?
Number two, can Donald Trump or any other
agency or department challenged this in total,
like challenge the law in total or specifically
challenge or request on the basis of that
particular request, not being a have but not
demonstrating a specific and legitimate legislative
purpose.
Number three, would the New York state tax
return if we were to see it, give us all or
most of the same information as Trump's federal
tax return?
The answer to that is we wouldn't get everything
from a New York state return that we would
from a federal tax return, but we would get
most of it.
And I am interested in this and I want to
see Donald Trump's taxes, but this is one
of those things where it's really important
for the left to manage expectations.
Should Donald Trump have released his tax
returns from the beginning?
Absolutely.
Do we want to see Donald Trump's tax returns
at this point in time?
Uh, even this late in the game?
Absolutely.
We do.
Our Trump's tax returns likely to reveal anything
that would be a blockbuster in terms of either
exposing criminality or effecting Donald Trump's
reelection.
It's not likely.
It's, it's just not likely.
It could expose that Donald Trump is not as
rich as he says, but his followers don't care.
They'll find excuses.
It might expose that Donald Trump pays very
little in taxes, but his followers will say
that makes him smart.
Well, that's the benefit of being in the Republican
Party that wants taxes lower, lower, lower,
no matter what the consequences that if you
find a way not to pay taxes as Donald Trump
may have successfully done for a long time
or pay very little in taxes, that's not, that's
seen as a feature, not a bug by the people
you're to get to vote for you.
And then lastly, uh, Richard Neil, my old
congressman from Massachusetts, who's the
person, uh, who has to request the tax returns
so far has said he's not going to request
them under this new law that he's going to,
I guess keep working on getting the federal
tax returns through some other means or something
like that.
Um, so this is news and I want to see the
tax returns, but it's important not to get
carried away here.
Let's keep an eye on what matters.
We want to stop Republican bills from becoming
the law.
We want to get Donald Trump out in 2020.
We want to pick up seats in the house in 2020.
We want to, to difficult map in the Senate
for Democrats in 2020, but we want to try
to not lose seats in the Senate as the case
may be and set up the 2022 election to maybe
lead to taking over control of the Senate.
And we need to, by the way, I keep saying
this and I've been saying it for years.
We need to make sure that the census is done
and done correctly while we continue fighting
voter suppression so that everybody who wants
to vote in 2020 not only is allowed to vote
but has their vote counted, which is another
layer that a, um, uh, Republicans have been
working very, very hard to destroy as a function
of democracy for many years, if not more than
a decade at this point in time.
So let's hopefully see the tax returns.
The tax returns are not going to be the blockbuster.
That may be some belief and much like, you
know, we would, if you were waiting around
for the molar report to say, we have video
of Trump and Putin personally colluding, you
are waiting for something all along.
That was never going to happen.
In the same way, if you're waiting for Trump's
tax returns to be such a blockbuster bombshell
that they lead to his removal or impeachment,
I mean it's just not going to happen.
And I would focus on things we can control.